Trascrizione: Alessandra Carfi'
Revisore: Michele Gianella
C'è un confine impalpabile,
in quella stanza d'ospedale.
In primo piano, il volto di una donna
completamente coperta da delle bende;
sullo sfondo, delle sagome di due figure,
coperti da camici e mascherine,
che continuano a parlare
di quell'operazione
che avrebbe dovuto restituire
i lineamenti a quella donna.
E un'attesa infinita,
seguita da un lentissimo
srotolamento di quelle bende,
che rivela un volto di donna bellissima.
Solo che, quando lei si vede
allo specchio, urla inorridita;
e solo in quel momento noi vediamo
come sono le facce delle altre persone.
Sono grottesche e mostruose,
ai nostri occhi;
ma in quel mondo rovesciato,
la sua bellezza è mostruosità,
e il suo disagio va trattato e va sedato.
Sono cresciuto con le storie
di "Ai confini delle realtà":
fantastiche,
persone ordinarie alle prese
con una situazione straordinaria;
e improvvisamente,
un colpo di scena finale
che cambia completamente,
ci costringe a cambiare la prospettiva
e ci dà una nuova consapevolezza
di quello che è successo,
una lettura completamente diversa.
E tutto sommato,
è quello che ci è successo
con questo dramma del Covid,
qualcosa di impensabile
che improvvisamente ci costringe
a guardare e rileggere tutto
in un modo diverso.
Credevo fossero soltanto storie belle;
invece, ho scoperto dopo anni
che in quelle storie c'era un condensato
delle ansie e delle paure di quegli anni:
il conformismo, la paura del diverso,
la xenofobia,
l'ossessione della guerra atomica.
Twilight, poi, sta per una linea soffusa:
quindi non è una linea ben definita,
è una sorta di linea di crepuscolo:
il confine tra la luce e l'ombra,
tra la fantasia e la realtà,
non è così ben definito,
e questo ci mette a disagio,
in qualche modo.
Ma non è una novità:
tutto sommato, è dall'inizio del Novecento
che l'arte figurativa -
ma non solo, anche la musica,
le linee della melodia, dell'armonia -
sono state in qualche modo scompaginate.
Questo ci ha creato un disagio,
ma contemporaneamente ha spostato
i confini della nostra conoscenza,
e li ha allargati.
Quindi sappiamo sempre di più.
Per non parlare, poi,
del confine tra spazio e tempo,
che forse è quello
che più ci mette a disagio.
Il problema, però, è che negli ultimi anni
la quantità di conoscenze
che ci arriva addosso,
la velocità con cui cambiano
e si spostano questi confini
è tale e tanta che noi siamo
completamente disorientati,
è una sorta di onda
che rischia di travolgerci.
Ed ecco il motivo
del successo delle fake news:
molti si vogliono aggrappare
a delle certezze granitiche:
se poi sono false non importa,
voglio essere confortato
da queste certezze.
Ma se, di fronte a quell'onda
che rischia di travolgerci,
ci fosse un'alternativa all'aggrapparsi
a dei salvagenti di granito?
Ho pochi minuti per cercare di convincervi
di quanto è importante
andare per disordine;
e, fidatevi, sono la persona giusta.
Sono cintura nera di CDC:
Collegamenti Del Cavolo.
E quindi, c'era una volta tre principi -
no, c'erano due volte tre principi.
I primi sono degli orfani hawaiani
che studiano vicino a San Francisco,
prendono uno dei primi treni
che arriva nel 1885 a Santa Cruz,
scoprono le stesse gigantesche onde
che ci sono nelle loro isole
e fanno qualcosa che nessuno
aveva visto fare,
e che impressiona
moltissimo i californiani -
tutto sommato, sono
gli abitanti di un territorio
che sta alla fine di questa corsa,
rischiosissima, verso ovest:
cavalcano le onde.
Questa metafora del controllare qualcosa
che non puoi controllare:
il surf.
Gli altri tre sono principi,
protagonisti di una favola
che fa parte di una raccolta
di favole persiane,
uscite a fine '500 a Venezia.
I tre principi di Serendip,
antico nome dello Sri Lanka,
sono dei giovani saggi e curiosi
che fanno scoperte
straordinarie, fantastiche
di cose che non stavano cercando,
ma che mai avrebbero trovato
se non si fossero messi alla ricerca.
Due secoli dopo Horace Walpole,
pioniere del Romanticismo,
in una lettera scritta a Firenze
cattura lo spirito di quella favola
e scrive con il neologismo
che oggi per noi è cruciale:
Serendipity.
Non è solo la storia
del signor Colombo Cristoforo,
che per andare in India
va dall'altra parte,
e sapete cosa è successo.
Una buona parte dei nostri
progressi scientifici,
delle invenzioni e delle scoperte
sono stati determinati
da scelte e da scoperte casuali,
ispirate però soltanto a persone
che erano messe alla ricerca.
E quindi, il surf che ci deve guidare
ovviamente è la curiosità.
Questo vuol dire
che trasformare l'onda
che ci sta per schiacciare
in qualcosa che ci fa volare
richiede di dimenticarsi tante cose
che abbiamo studiato a scuola -
i collegamenti razionali, le cronologie -
e calcolando dei percorsi
che sono connessioni
eccentriche, e strampalate,
si cattura in quella complessità
un significato che sfugge
al pensiero lineare,
una metafora del pensiero laterale.
E dunque, io salto e faccio
alcune di queste connessioni.
Tutte le nostre storie sono legate
a storie di qualcun altro;
e la mia, mi fa piacere sia stato citato,
è legata a quella di un papà cronista
che mi ha insegnato
la curiosità per le storie,
facendomi fare quel che lui
non aveva potuto fare:
studiare e viaggiare.
Il disordine mentale ce l'ho messo io,
ma quella curiosità l'ha innescata lui;
ed è stata cruciale,
in qualche modo cruciale
quando, una dozzina d'anni fa,
abbiamo deciso di scommettere
sul futuro dei nostri figli,
io e mia moglie,
mandandoci da soli
per sei mesi in California.
Me l'hanno detto tanti
che non era una roba
che tutti potevano fare,
perché ci voleva la moglie giusta;
ma per fortuna io l'avevo.
E quindi, siamo andati per sei mesi.
I ragazzi hanno studiato lì,
è stata un'esperienza
indimenticabile, per loro;
ma per me è stato un terremoto.
Ho deciso di conoscere, di diventare amico
di molti italiani di Silicon Valley
e questo è diventato un percorso
nel talento, nell'identità italiana
che mai mi sarei aspettato,
al punto che al ritorno, poco dopo,
ho deciso che questo
sarebbe stato il mio lavoro.
E quindi da Sixth Saint John,
dove abitiamo, Sesto San Giovanni appunto,
a Palo Alto nel cuore di Silicon Valley,
di cui non dirò
praticamente nulla o quasi.
Parlerò di quello che ho capito,
o credo di aver capito,
con queste connessioni balenghe.
Due storie.
Questa volta invece che il surf, la canoa.
Una è la canoa
che Giacomo Costantino Beltrami trascina
camminando per giorni nel Mississippi,
passando dove nessun
altro bianco è passato
e arrivando ad una delle sorgenti.
Sembra sia stato lui
ad ispirare a Fenimore Cooper
"L'ultimo dei Mohicani".
L'altra è la canoa con cui Paolo Andreani,
nobile conte irrequieto -
così irrequieto milanese
che a 21 anni ha sconvolto
la Milano illuminista
facendo, con un'impresa
che molti pensavano suicida -
è la prima persona dopo i Montgolfier
a salire col pallone aerostatico -
fa una circumnavigazione
dei Grandi Laghi, nel 1790,
raccogliendo documenti
estremamente importanti:
centinaia di miglia sulla canoa.
Che cos'hanno di particolare?
Che dove gli altri, tutti gli altri,
vedevano dei selvaggi da eliminare,
o forse da trasformare in civili,
Paolo Andreani coglie
la profondità e la spiritualità
e scrive delle cose terribili,
che i neonati Stati Uniti d'America
prendono molto male,
su quello che vedeva succedere
nello sterminio degli indiani.
Giacomo Costantino Beltrami,
in questo ed in altri viaggi,
raccoglie dei manufatti che oggi
hanno un valore inestimabile.
Questi due italiani vedono qualche cosa -
una civiltà profonda,
il valore di un artigianato di qualità
che per gli altri era
assolutamente invisibile.
Avevano studiato?
No, si portavano in quell'avventura
su quella frontiera
una conoscenza, un gusto estetico,
una profondità di pensiero
che gli altri pionieri esploratori
non potevano avere.
Le storie che ho raccontato
di questi due italiani
le ha raccolte il mio amico,
oggi uno dei più grandi esperti mondiali
di nativi americani, Cesare Marino.
La connessione però che voglio seguire
esce da delle parole bellissime
sul talento italiano,
che aveva pronunciato anni fa Renzo Piano:
"Cosa abbiamo di particolare?
Siamo tutti nani
sulle spalle di un gigante.
Il gigante", dice, "è la cultura
che ci ha preceduti,
che ci dà una sottile, invisibile capacità
di affrontare la complessità delle cose,
tessere arte e scienza insieme,
articolare i ragionamenti.
Un'italianità
che non ha nulla a che vedere
con l'orgoglio nazionalistico
e che trova un posto a tavola
in tutto il mondo".
Ho ripensato a questa storia
perché incredibilmente
quello che Cesare Marino,
per 40 anni antropologo allo Smithsonian,
mi aveva raccontato del suo ingresso
in un mondo che sembrava impenetrabile
coincideva con quello che Luca Prasso,
un mio amico di Verona
che oggi si definisce archeologo
della realtà virtuale a Google,
ma quando lo avevo incontrato, 12 anni fa.
era un pioniere della grafica digitale,
a Dreamworks.
Qualcosa di più diverso,
tra grafica digitale e antropologia?
Ma il loro percorso da italiani,
incredibilmente, è sempre lo stesso.
Ho l'occasione della vita di entrare
nella Mecca assoluta del mio settore:
Dreamworks e Smithsonian.
Vado, non mi prenderanno mai,
è il posto che sognano
tutti i grandi super esperti del mondo.
E quasi subito, tutti e due
mi dicono di aver capito
che era il contrario,
perché la loro conoscenza
e la loro esperienza
non era così, ma era così.
Quello che pensavano fosse il punto debole
si è rivelato il punto di forza
del loro percorso professionale.
Cosa abbiamo di particolare?
Lo ha spiegato meglio ancora,
qualche anno fa,
la persona che è stato, forse,
il mentore principale della mia avventura
e senza il quale, forse,
oggi non saremmo qui;
perché Federico Faggin, vicentino,
è la persona che ha firmato
il primo microchip -
qua sempre con persone importanti,
qualcuno lo prende un po' meno sul serio -
Ha firmato il primo microchip
e poi ha realizzato la tecnologia touch,
che molti credono sia stata
realizzata da Apple,
ma Apple l'ha realizzata
dopo che Steve Jobs
aveva tentato, inutilmente,
di averla in esclusiva da Federico.
"Se guardo come ho disegnato
il primo microchip,
ci trovo una bellezza estetica.
Mi rendo conto che essere nato e vissuto
nella città del Palladio, del classicismo,
ti lascia dentro qualcosa
di assolutamente inconsapevole.
Di fronte ad un problema complesso,
io ho dato a questo problema una soluzione
con una bellezza estetica, con un'armonia"
È questo che abbiamo, di particolare:
a fronte di un problema complesso,
noi italiani riusciamo a vedere
delle angolazioni diverse.
Non solo l'aspetto tecnico,
ma un risvolto di estetica,
anche un risvolto etico
e un collegamento
con la cultura umanistica.
"Se ripensiamo", lui ha detto,
"a Leonardo, o a Marconi,
c'è proprio dietro questa capacità.
Altri sono molto più bravi
a fare business,
e sviluppare il business su un prodotto;
ma noi abbiamo questa visione d'insieme,
che ha un grandissimo valore".
E ho trovato esattamente
la stessa filosofia
in questo splendido libro
in cui David Epstein, qualche tempo fa,
ha smentito un luogo comune:
quello dei super specialisti.
È un bestseller del New York Times,
questo "Range",
che dice che in un mondo
di super specialisti
sono i generalisti quelli
che sono destinati a trionfare,
perché le connessioni
tra cose diverse, spesso,
escono da persone che non sono
super specialisti di un campo,
ma che sanno creare questi collegamenti.
In un'infinità di casi,
dallo sport alle scienze cognitive,
dai grandi problemi ambientali
o della ricerca scientifica,
l'idea giusta è venuta da una persona
che ha saputo abbinare
e collegare cose diverse,
È il motivo per cui dobbiamo ricordare
e celebrare i nostri connazionali
che hanno saputo fare questo
ad un livello straordinario;
ma lo hanno fatto forse troppo presto,
al punto che oggi
sono ricordati, e celebrati,
molto più all'estero che non in Italia.
Che qualcuno di recente
si sia ispirato a questi negozi,
per vendere i suoi computer?
L'idea di Adriano Olivetti
non è soltanto quella di un'impresa
straordinariamente innovativa:
è quella di saper combinare,
in quella ricerca
di tecnologia e di prodotto,
l'etica, l'estetica,
coinvolgere grandi intellettuali,
scienziati e non solo, scrittori, artisti.
E, come se non bastasse,
con una visione umanistica:
la fabbrica non solo
come luogo di produzione,
ma come luogo di comunità tra persone.
Silicon Valley forse non è
una comunità di persone;
ma per quanto incredibile,
tutti questi grandi protagonisti
dell'innovazione mondiale
hanno qualcosa in comune:
da piccoli hanno studiato nelle scuole
che hanno seguito il metodo
creato da una grandissima
visionaria dell'Ottocento.
Maria Montessori non è solo la persona
che ha saputo applicare
la ricerca scientifica alla pedagogia.
È molto di più:
è una che trova un metodo
per valorizzare i bambini con handicap,
e con risultati miracolosi
sul recupero di questi bambini.
E quando quel metodo
viene applicato a bambini normali,
ha un effetto esplosivo
nella capacità di intercettare
e valorizzare questo talento.
È quello che hanno detto molti
dei protagonisti visti prima -
Brin e Page per primi.
Qual è stata la vera chiave
del loro successo?
Da bambini, essere spinti
a sfidare i confini,
a credere in se stessi.
Ma c'è qualcosa in più,
nella filosofia di Maria Montessori,
che oggi ci deve coinvolgere.
E cioè l'idea di attribuire
a chi viene dopo di noi, ai bambini,
un ruolo salvifico.
Non sono contenitori in cui noi
dobbiamo mettere delle istruzioni,
o devono semplicemente apprendere.
No, sono loro la nostra
scommessa sul futuro.
E quindi noi dobbiamo investire
e puntare su di loro,
perché saranno loro, e non saremo noi,
a poter salvare il mondo in cui viviamo.
Il valore di tutto questo
me l'ha spiegato al meglio
un mio amico di LinkedIn,
un veterano anche lui Olivetti.
Perché tutta questa capacità
di combinare ha questa importanza?
"Non smetterò di ammirare
la capacità degli italiani
di sentirsi a proprio agio
nella complessità,
anche quando questa ha
le caratteristiche del caos"
mi ha detto Fabio.
Gli americani, ma direi gli anglosassoni,
sono portati a semplificare
per tentare di risolvere
un po' alla volta.
Ma a fronte della complessità
che abbiamo davanti,
non credo più che questo sistema funzioni,
e un approccio all'italiana
sarebbe molto utile
anche a Silicon Valley.
La lezione di Montessori,
con cui voglio concludere,
è proprio questa.
E si richiama un po'
a queste parole bellissime
dette dal protagonista
di un film, Interstellar,
in cui la sfida al confine dello spazio
si intreccia con la sfida
al rapporto spazio/tempo.
Abbiamo parlato a lungo
di muri, di barriere, di proteggerci:
e poi, improvvisamente,
come nei "confini della realtà"
è uscito qualcosa di piccolissimo
che nessun muro,
nessuna barriera può bloccare.
Abbiamo dovuto per forza cambiare
la nostra prospettiva
e la nostra consapevolezza:
capire, probabilmente,
che la nostra salvezza
non si potrà realizzare
chiudendo porte in faccia a qualcun altro,
ma o ci salviamo tutti o non ci salviamo.
E dobbiamo farlo
sperando su quelli
che vengono dopo di noi,
ricordando queste bellissime parole
che dice il protagonista di Interstellar:
"Ci siamo dimenticati chi siamo:
pionieri, esploratori e non guardiani".
E questo è quello che dobbiamo lasciare
a quelli che vengono dopo di noi:
non tanto conoscenza,
quanto togliere le macerie culturali
e le tante zavorre
che bloccano il loro talento,
sicuri che loro affronteranno,
supereranno e risolveranno
dei confini di cui noi
non abbiamo la minima idea.
Noi dobbiamo solo ispirarli
e liberare il loro talento.
Raccontare storie, e incrociarle,
ci aiuterà a farlo.
Grazie.
(Applausi)